again is sex in marriage or relationship
an obligation
no you should enjoy it obligation
every time he wants to bend you over are
you letting him put it inside you is
what i'm saying oh if you're married
or relationship
honestly guys about feelings like i'm
saying if the answer is no and he seeks
it elsewhere
is that a problem you're going to say
yes but see but that's that's that's
messed up so then because because you
know what i'm saying i'm saying because
you're just thinking about what you want
[Laughter]
because a lot of times they have kids
with the girl
and so you're adding stuff to the stuff
okay
in the context of marriage yes that's
correct and the con context of a
relationship act called just bounce so
when you're married it's a difference
what are your what are your obligations
from a man
for you
in a relationship
what do you what do you want from a man
like what is he obligated to for you in
a relationship well i'm saying loyalties
up there trust loyalties up there that's
that's a must but then if you guys are
saying that no no for you just
obligation from a man yeah just for you
yeah just those two things well that's
one of them i can't think and list them
all up but yeah the main one is loyalty
and
to respect me love me all of that stuff
that's that's
up there that's well what if he says
i'm only doing that for someone that's
my wife i'll respect you but i'm out
you can't be loyal or respect me but you
want to be with me you only be
respectful and loyal to your wife
so then either you put a ring on this or
i'm gone that's it what if he said i'm
gone unless you give me sex on demand
i'm going as well then you're gone
what the hell what did you what if you
don't you don't think sex is a duty in
marriage but she just always my marriage
you're dating i'm confused like you keep
changing it it's not marriage i'm
usually talking in the context of
marriage but i don't know i'm not
married so i can't say that i'm not
married and i still can't speak on
marriage i've never been married i'm not
i mean i even think in a relationship
honestly if he's not sleeping with
anyone else yeah you should give him sex
whenever he wants whatever he wants yeah
because like why should he even go get
it because guys guys
guys want to [ __ ] all the time so if i'm
saying like please don't [ __ ] other
girls just [ __ ] me like then i should
okay i understand that but then if
there's just a one day where it's like
i'm not in it right now or i'm on my or
whatever you're not using obviously
does that mean that he now has a right
to go and have sex with someone
obviously he's not one day come on let's
be let's be real about it like that's
that's what i'm saying but you guys are
making it sound i'll give you one day
i'll give you one day
if you miss work one day they might give
you a pass of two days in a row
you might you might be getting a pink
slip
scenario that you gave us earlier about
um you're you're messed with your man
and work
i was about to say that yeah women
aren't feeling well
but they got all cold
they will still go to work
but if their man wants some sex they got
excuses for it they've got a headache
but they never got headache to go to
work
like we're saying that a man actually is
going to cheat or he's cheating because
you didn't give it enough
yes that happened that's nice
scenario i don't think it's always like
that
okay
it's like you're not showing up to work
and you're mad they gotta temp while
you're gone
at least you're at least your job's
still there for when you get back
at least i didn't fire you
just to tell them
i just think that's the duty to have sex
with your man whenever he wants it
however he wants it yeah it's it's like
why about the opposite go for it well
whenever you want listen if you want to
have sex
guys guys guys before we go again and
let's just reiterate some rules i know
we've got some new people on the panel
but guys one at a time i cannot hear you
they can't hear you please let's do this
say that again free up give them
understanding
as far as i'm concerned we may need to
free up all the time andy what if he
wanted what if he's at work what should
i drive to your workplace
what if we're at the grocery store
they got taught in grocery stores
[Laughter]
what if we're at the library i don't
care just don't make no noise
what if we're at a concert listen i'm
taking it wherever wherever he wants it
i'm gonna be cooking i could be washing
that washing machine
what if you're on a podcast
if it's only friends i'm getting paid
for it yeah i'll have a go
but i just think you need to do it all
the time i have a question for you two
ladies because when auntie's talking
about that earlier she was talking about
it we were like yeah if that's my man if
that's my husband why wouldn't i
you two right now your facial expression
your body language is
when she's talking about it it's like no
i wouldn't do that if he wants it i
wouldn't do that all the time no no
if if no but if if you want sex all the
time and that's your man or whatever
then fair enough have sex but the point
i'm trying to get is
you could be giving him you could be
throwing it back do like you could be
giving it to him all day every day he
will still go somewhere else see someone
has the choice to cheat she's there and
i'll still have sex with her even though
my girl is giving it to me every day
okay live but life's nice
life's about trade-offs real life's
about trade-offs
no no but i'm saying so like i just i'll
explain so life is about trade-offs so
you can either pick a guy that other
women want and know he might cheat on
you or you can pick a guy that no other
women want and he won't cheat on you but
the thing is girls pick the guys that
other women want to bang he might cheat
but how would how would you know you you
you know and the thing is like girls act
stupid like no that no i'm not i'm not
i'm not talking about you i'm not
talking about you girls will act stupid
like they don't know this guy might
cheat
like but they know they know what like
you you can feel it on a guy if he gets
a lot of girls
honestly if i can express my point of
view i wasn't like about uh the fact if
i love that man i will definitely at sex
with him whenever he wants because i
want it i want it come on but if you
actually if you actually
if you're actually talking about like
i have two
that's another point i don't have to i
want it it's different like in a
marriage it's supposed to be like that i
have desire i want you because i love
you because there's something between us
not because you ask me that's one of my
duty which is different i don't have
duty for one day i'm sick and like i
just add that baby let's say
men like you know what i agree with you
i agree with you do you know the problem
is i think a lot of women are quite
idealistic about future so a lot of
women think about as i am now in a
relationship when you've been there for
30 years your feelings and emotions
remember you're going to change they're
going to be less you know what makes
sense
honestly
let auntie talk where auntie talks
you and your woman having good sex and
she gets 20 years older 30 years older
she said no i'm too old she's talking
rubbish banger
right she's talking about rubbish
[Applause]
especially you know not makes me sick
about some women especially like
wesleyan women when they get a house
they will get the priest to come around
they're blessed but they don't want to
go around and bless every room with
their man
there is not a room in my house that i
haven't performed in oh wow every house
that i've been outperformed because you
know what i'm blessing the house i can't
sit down in that yard
i don't care sweaty cheeks everywhere
the whole house for the time when you
move in because it's true they always
get the priest round
how come you don't disagree man you know
that's chris in this room and there's
chris in that room and excuse us in the
other room let's explore yeah go for it
and women does this get to the point oh
i'm getting too old rubbish if your
woman's getting too old go out there and
find somebody else that's young enough
for you i'm telling you go out there
because as far as i'm concerned leave
her out move around right all the way
just lie down and as far as i'm
concerned if you've got the right man
and you're not in the mood
right you gotta he'll get you in the
mood
he will get you a little choker in there
are you telling me
i mean
grab this would you mean come here